agradezco de manera sincera la
participación del presidente biden y del
Primer Ministro Justin
también la de sus señoras esposas
y Sofi así como de sus acompañantes
y de sus equipos de trabajo
el solo hecho de reunirnos
como buenos vecinos
en un ambiente de respeto para buscar
juntos el bienestar de nuestros pueblos
ya es en sí mismo un acontecimiento
histórico
sin embargo destaco
que acordamos fortalecer nuestras
relaciones económicas y comerciales
para lo cual se creará
un comité conjunto
destinado a la planeación
y a la
sustitución de importaciones en América
del Norte
procurar ser cada vez más
autosuficientes
así como para hacer realidad el
desarrollo la cooperación y el bienestar
de todos los países
de nuestro continente
Estados Unidos Canadá y México
propondrán cada uno
a cuatro integrantes
para la formación de este grupo de doce
especialistas
que además de ser conocedores
de la materia del tema en cuestión
contarán
con nuestra absoluta confianza para
motivar persuadir y convencer
a empresarios a trabajadores
y a servidores públicos de los tres
gobiernos
acerca de la importancia de la
trascendencia
de
unirnos en América del Norte
y
Buscar hacia adelante la unión en todo
el continente americano
por parte de México
en este grupo
nos representará Marcelo ebrard
secretario de relaciones exteriores
[Música]
Rogelio Ramírez de la O
secretario de Hacienda y Crédito Público
Raquel buenrostro Sánchez secretaria de
economía
y Alfonso Romo Garza en su carácter de
empresario independiente
también abordamos
como asunto prioritario
la integración económica y comercial
como ya lo expresé
de todo el continente americano
así como el bienestar de los pueblos y
las nuevas relaciones de cooperación
dejando atrás el intervencionismo
hegemónico
Yo abro un paréntesis para
expresar mi reconocimiento al Primer
Ministro trudó al presidente biden
por la manera
tan
solidaria
en que actuaron
ante el intento de golpe de estado
en Brasil
esto demuestra de que hay un compromiso
auténtico
en favor
de la democracia
nuestro apoyo al presidente Lula de
Brasil
tenemos
que
lograr juntos
lo dicho por el presidente
que en un pie de igualdad
nos tratemos como buenos vecinos
aliados económicos
y como amigos
nosotros por supuesto ayudaríamos a
convertir este sueño
en realidad
y nos entusiasma
la certeza de que se puede lograr
la Paz es fruto de la justicia
los problemas sociales no se resuelven
solo con medidas coercitivas
debemos siempre atender el flagelo de la
violencia y el fenómeno migratorio
con un enfoque
humanitario
y de oportunidades para el bienestar
las personas son buenas por naturaleza
y son las circunstancias las que a veces
obligan algunos a tomar el camino de las
conductas antisociales
nosotros lo hemos constatado
en México
también en
[Música]
los pueblos hermanos
los países de Honduras y en El Salvador
por ejemplo en nuestro país
como no se permite la corrupción
y el presupuesto se destina al
desarrollo
y apoyar
a los más pobres
ahora no solo hay
empleos
ha bajado la violencia
es menos la migración
también
se ha atemperado
la frustración
y permanece encendida la llama
de la esperanza
la Paz
es fruto
de la justicia
el caso de Centroamérica es excepcional
con muy pocos recursos
estamos ayudando a productores de
comunidades en Honduras y El Salvador
para que siempre en sus tierras y
cuenten con asesoría técnica sustento e
ingresos básicos
y en los pueblos donde estamos aplicando
estas acciones en particular el programa
de sembrando vida y el de jóvenes
construyendo el futuro no solo se ha
reducido la cantidad de personas que
desean emigrar hacia Estados Unidos en
busca de oportunidades de trabajo y de
mejores condiciones de vida sino que
para muchos jóvenes la delincuencia ha
dejado de ser la única posibilidad de
sobrevivencia y de salir adelante
el tema migratorio como otros fue
tratado con amplitud
y se llegaron a importantes acuerdos
entre los tres países En beneficio de
nuestros pueblos
como se podrá constatar como ustedes
van
a saberlo
a través de un comunicado conjunto que
se les entregará
de manera inmediata
por último Quiero agradecer al Primer
Ministro
yo se introdujo por su extraordinario
y fraterno programa
que consiste en otorgar visas temporales
de trabajo
a jornaleros obreros
[Música]
Este programa ya beneficia
a 25 mil hombres y mujeres
25 mil mexicanos
es
un camino a seguir
el de la migración
ordenada
el Primer Ministro dudó es un gran
Aliado de México
al presidente bailen
mi agradecimiento sincero por mantener
con México una relación de cooperación
de amistad sincera
de respeto
a nuestros paisanos que viven y trabajan
honradamente en Estados Unidos
y que no son acosados
ni padecen de redadas como sucedía
Lamentablemente
en otros tiempos
Ya lo hemos dicho y lo repito ahora
usted es el primer presidente de Estados
Unidos en mucho tiempo
que no ha construido ni un metro de muro
Y eso
se lo agradecemos
aunque no les guste
a los
conservadores
de manera especial
quiero dejar de manifiesto que le he
solicitado
respetuosamente al presidente biden
que se insista y sé que no es
un asunto sencillo
pero
[Música]
es justo
y por eso lo planteo
además
le tengo
plena confianza al presidente baile
y le he pedido que insista ante el
congreso de Estados Unidos para
regularizar la situación migratoria de
millones de mexicanos que llevan años
viviendo trabajando y contribuyendo en
el desarrollo
de esa gran nación que es Estados Unidos
he reafirmado que el presidente biden
es un hombre con convicciones
que mantiene principios ideales para
garantizar
como
muchos otros mujeres hombres en Estados
Unidos y en el mundo
que la Estatua de la Libertad
nunca jamás
se convierta en un símbolo vacío
termino diciendo que mi maestro el gran
poeta Carlos pellicer
en 1930 sostenía
que el anhelo de la libertad es el más
grande fruto que ha cuajado el corazón
humano
para ser justos es necesario ser libres
los sentimientos de justicia son hijos
de la libertad
pues nunca nunca siendo esclavos
podremos
ser justos
Muchas gracias